what seems important to me is to
consider that one of the
main issues that is in front of us
and first of all simply
the eyes and to see what will be made of
what will be made of the next 20
years
first of all renewal  full
international order with an
extremely strong development of asia
the 20th century will be the century
of asia a very important development
that we often forget about africa which
has a crucial impact for eastern europe
faced with these situations which present
many opportunities the need
for europe for the united states to
reflect on their positioning therefore a
complete renewal of the international landscape
at the same time and this is a point
we repeat in vain we still have
difficulties to consider it in a
concrete way is that the planet remains
vulnerable
the water problems of
climate change when we think for example
that we have only two years in front of
us to change our lifestyles  ie so
that the climate change which is
today the subject of an
international consensus is not irreversible
what are we doing in the next 2 5 8 years
to deal with this
extremely important moment
third element is development
migrations and exchanges which will
allow people to meet but
which will also lead to intercultural dialogues
which will perhaps be more
complicated more stormy than in the past
these are facts to face these
challenges in the face of these facts I believe that  'it
is important to think about the mode of
international governance the system
that came out of the second world war
but today a system that is more
adapted to the issues that we have a
treaty
second subject is where the
sovereignty of  more and more
people have lost the thread of
politics because they know that
the evolution of the world has resulted in a
relinquishment of sovereignty at
the national level whereas  e democratic processes
remain national how
do we invent new processes
new identities new
new sense of belonging at
the state level but at ten more
global levels so that the global decisions
we make on all its
global public goods that are the sea
oceans the land the air the regulation
of the financial markets that all these
questions are the subject of answers that
they are that they are legitimate